you told me yesterday
people are bound to continue to beat you
up do you feel beaten at the moment no
no
i was speaking uh metaphorically and
what i mean is that when you're the the
leader of a country in good times and in
bad you have to think about the
criticisms that you get and
you have to recognize that you the
people inevitably when you're the head
of a government that's taking country
through a big inflationary price spike
caused by the increasing cost of energy
people are frustrated people are
filling up their cars and and and
cursing uh as they do so i understand
that we have to help them and i
understand people's frustration so what
i'm saying is that
politics is about allowing people to
have the the democratic safety valve of
letting off
at governments but then such as in
in by-elections but then the job of a
leader is to say well
you know what is the criticism that
really matters here and i think you know
back to what i was saying to you just
now i think it's that for a long time
people were hearing not enough about the
things that really matters them far too
much about it the criticism was about
you sir that's right it was it was about
you that's right and i think what people
were hearing but you said you do
acknowledge that it's part you are part
of the problem well what i certainly
think is that if you look at the
by-elections uh people were
absolutely fed up about hearing about
things that i'd stuffed up uh endless
turn of stuff and what they wanted to
hear was well
yeah yeah but what is this guy
what is this guy doing and so i want to
talk about our plan to help people with
the cost of living what we're doing for
a stronger economy our plan for a
stronger economy but also of course what
we're doing so here in in kigali in in
germany and then at nato to stand up
against just just to follow up on that
it's not just voters it's also your
backbenchers whether you like it or
disagree with them they're now talking
back home about changing the 22 rules
again for another confidence but it's
not just voters angry with you is it
what's your response
to those mps that want to change the
rules and force another so my response
is golden rule rule number one of
politics is uh
focus on what we're doing what we've
been elected to do to help people take
the the country forward i think that
my party the conservative government uh
the conservative party can be very proud
of having delivered some pretty tough
things we got brexit done when people
thought it was impossible uh we got the
fastest vaccine rally in europe we've
got lowest unemployment for a a very
long time uh we led the world in helping
uh to support the ukrainians and we're
now thanks to the sensible management of
the economy in a position to help people
to cross the country give me 1200
my message is to focus on what matters
okay to everyone else
okay let's talk about ourselves let's
talk about it i haven't got long left as
i first so let's move on to things that
matter to voters as well although i do
think partygate did matter to voters and
that was
part of the problem wasn't it it did
matter i think i think the
certainly people were were absolutely
fed up about about hearing about that
again and again and again and and yeah i
think it was and the number of fines i
think i think it was something that
showed that uh to them that we needed to
focus on the stuff okay let's focus on
it because there is an issue of trust
and people believe in what you say in
october last year i asked you if you
worried about inflation and you told me
fears over inflation were to quote you
unfounded it's just hit a 40-year high
and is now at 9.1 percent why did you
say that because at that time there were
people there were people who were uh who
had uh i think uh forecast higher rates
and but what i'm saying
it's clearly an issue that we have to
get that wrong though it's clearly an
issue that we have to to deal with now
and i think you know let's let's be
absolutely uh clear the the management
of inflation over the last 25 years has
been done
by the independent uh bank of england i
think
overall they've done an outstanding job
they've kept it uh about two percent uh
but what we need to do
is what we as government need to do is
find
all the ways we can to take out cost for
people up and down the country so that's
so let me give you some examples we
aren't going to run out of time though
fixing our energy markets uh making sure
that we
reform our transport system sorting out
our our housing and our planning system
to reduce the cost of housing which is a
huge part of people's uh people's
budgets so we're taking short-term
action with cash that we have that we've
built up to help people but also
fixing the underlying
side problems tax cuts because you said
yesterday you're now freezing and i
contribute some fool jose's jesus you
said i know it won't shake your thirst
or satiate your appetite for tax cuts
but it shows the direction we're trying
to go in so in principle more tax cuts
next year i don't need to give you rishi
sunak and i are both instinctively
believers that if you can
let people spend their own money uh if
you can reduce uh the costs and the
regulatory burdens or unnecessary
regulatory burdens on business then you
will drive stronger economic growth so
our plan for a stronger economy
certainly includes responsible tax next
year they are coming in next month in
the form of big cuts to people's
national insurance contributions
additional tax cuts next year we've
already put in cuts to uh
and fuel duty additional tax cuts next
year and
i know you want me to to go further but
it's not me it's people that can't pay
their bills and of course we will do
what we can but what will help what
we're doing immediately to help people
is cutting uh
the taxes that i've i've mentioned but
also uh giving people the cash that they
need uh to tide them over we hope in
tough times i'm not going to pretend
beth that we can the government can go
around fixing uh every problem um and
the
uh
this global inflation
problems that we've got talk to
everybody here at the at the
commonwealth uh they're tough uh we've
got we've got a spike in the cost of a
food fertilizer fuel i'm going to ask
you one more thing and then i've got to
finish because one thing you can do
is help public sector workers with wages
lots of calls for pay rises across the
public sector
but am i right in saying that nurses
teachers the police are going to have to
settle for a real terms pay cut next
year no
the pay review bodies will have to make
their their recommendations uh but what
i would and you know generally you set
the parameters the government sets the
parameters generally speaking what we've
had in the last
few years is uh significant pancreas
thank you for 5 million public sector
workers
remember what we did for for nurses as
soon as i came in tried to give them
this more support uh we've you know
we've invested massively in the in the
police that you that you mentioned um
what we what we can't have is a
situation in which
increases in pay are just wiped out by
further increases in prices and so
that's why you've got to be responsible
i know but when private sector pay rise
are currently running at eight percent
and you're targeting two to three
percent
will you at least consider a slightly
higher target than that i mean people
are really struggling i just you know
just of course i get that of course i
get that i'm not going to
what we what we must do is be
responsible and ensure that people's
increases in pay which i want to see but
like not white people
the railways what we want to see
for instance uh uh
in that area
um whether you know
increa demands for increased uh uh wages
you know train drivers around 59 000 uh
some trade drivers twenty percent of
train drivers on seventy thousand pounds
fine that they wanna go they wanna go on
strike uh
no their union leaders do
i would say
given the circumstances we're in
i think
you know what we want to see is reform
and improvement in the way the railways
work and modernization and we've got 25
percent fall in in ridership which we've
got at the moment you've got the
government putting billions and i mean
we're putting more into the railways
than any previous government i think the
travelling public has a right to expect
some basic reforms like with ticket
offices like with walking time and and
some of these other practices that
really nobody defends except the union
leaders